ce sont des concerts
allez
je pense oui
des gens
acharné on a eu la chance de passer par
l'étape 2 des concerts en fait avant
même d'avoir 4000e like sur facebook
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas encore
instagram à ce moment là qui pétait je
suis très très content d'avoir vécu
quand même l'histoire avec lors du
commun genre vraiment le début dans des
cafés avec 30 personnes
bonjour bon c'était beaucoup de stress
j'avais des boule au ventre je n'étais
pas bien je mangeais pas beaucoup
j'étais stressée je m'épuise et je me
casser la voix gt gt cassé à la fin et
ouais maintenant ça a complètement
changé
c'est plus du tout la même manière de
voir un conte cirque avant mais le
plaisir encore et encore plus encore
plus fort se trouve maintenant parce
qu'on contrôle
ouais tranquille selon la saison
prochaine en faire l année beaucoup les
gens avant un show le seul truc que je
vais vraiment à chaque fois c'est garder
la wachau documentant possible donc
rangé les ustensiles de fumette les
éloigner au maximum un thermos pourrait
avoir le plus souvent possible de l'eau
chaude sur soi pendant on va dire une
heure avant j'essaye d'aller mettre en
loge et plus trop parler aux autres
parce que il ya le stress qui commence
même si je disais que j'étais pas trop
stressé il ya un petit peu de tension
qui monte et je sais que je peux être
très vite désagréable avec les gars qui
vont me dire ça va je veux leur dire ben
ouais ça va tu es con quoi tu vois des
baies truc comme ça alors je vais me
cacher
plus de 45 e
c'est important de se souvient la bouffe
du coup
ce soit une captation ses films et ses
recteurs transcrit à la télé enfin
concrètement on a affiché ensemble elles
tenues qui pouvait bien passer à l'écran
une photo très bien s'ils avaient être
des le fénoir des baskets ou des lacs et
poitrail avec tous là j'avais vraiment
aucun style sur scène je veux toujours
la même tenue mais ça change tout
[Musique]
une plateforme kim élèves tout en haut
de la scène chaque rocher avec un
harnais et puis je descends j'ai pas un
je suis pas avec mes musiciens sur nos
départs de la scène on se retrouve juste
avant en fait trop tu commences à parler
et puis ça monte puis on crie et on
criera et on n'entend pas les gens s'il
ya ce soir peut-être qu'ils sont pas
aussi ouf parce qu'il réagisse pas
n'importe quoi tu vois
des mythes remplir des trucs comme ça
avec 7000 personnes qui connaissent la
plupart tout le truc c'est difficile on
pourra se dire ouais c'est normal à
trouver ça normal encore
tu es footballeur
jallet
[Musique]
je montrais permet aux banques
secondaires au lycée puis à faire
parti en 175 ces trois années d'études
et plus les années passaient et plus est
vraiment sur lui pour dire c'est même la
croisée mais
alors commis ces diplomates
petit et durs ont tourné autour du pot
mon époque nous et ses textes voix alain
tartas j'étais déjà mexes tu vois que tu
es un truc vraiment spécial quoi tu es
obligé faire j'ai toujours cru en lui et
ouvre trop confiance et servait d'école
autre voie que demain au crossa concert
on se laisse pas qu'ils vivent plus
souffrir
montre joie
[Musique]
c'est bien c'est notre papa une autre
maman celui tous bien que ce soit un
opticien un technicien il n'y a pas de
différence 40 ans et on s'est tous bien
trouvée franchement c'est les et projets
géants allemands commencent à séduire 2
- cé
enfin s'initier aux plaisirs leur style
génial rapporté
le meilleur hélas il
trop contente d'être mise à mort de
france me croît de d'avoir réussi à
remonter ce sens et c'est un sentiment
d'accomplissement génial
il ya quasiment que des amis de longue
date dans l'équipe et les gens qui se
sont rajoutés après se sont très vite
adaptés aux à l'ambiance qu'il y avait
en général c'était pas un objectif
stratégique ou quoi que ce soit ça s'est
fait avec le coeur en fête tout
simplement
j'étais avec mes amis depuis le début
j'ai pas voulu arrêter avec eux et à
chaque fois que je me suis lié d'amitié
avec une équipe avec des producteurs
avec des tourneurs tous les gens avec
qui j'ai travaillé une fois que j'ai
vécu une aventure avec ces gens là j'ai
eu envie de la poursuivre le plus
longtemps et encore aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'il nous c'est ce qui fait qu'on ait
jeté type comme ça c'est que c'est
vraiment super fraternelle
[Applaudissements]
hello
[Musique]
ces rapports
pour avaler
[Musique]
voilà
je
la route
cela